well Paulie thank you so much for
joining us today it's a pleasure to have
you open campus oh thanks for making the
journey well thank you for having me
here Julia
well we are very excited and we are such
reality buffs here so this is a real
treat to have you in studio I wanted to
start right where last week's episode or
this week's episode of the challenge
ended off you're alone in the jungle
on the ground you're gassed out and they
your partners have left you like what in
that moment were you thinking honestly
at that point you know I just got I got
heat stroke you know and I had told them
prior to the final starting like look
hey if anybody's struggling don't leave
him behind but I said but if it's me I
said leave me behind
cuz I'll I'll figure it out you know
what I mean but at that point I really I
don't even remember that so like
watching the episode you know it it
reminds me of the conditioning I always
did with my brain if I was ever in a
life-or-death situation and just kind of
be like figure it out body don't die but
I don't remember that like when I when I
watched saying to a car like I can't see
right now I don't remember seeing
anything I don't remember the
conversations I literally was blacked
out for that moment you know I mean I
exhausted myself and and it's and it
sucks you know I maybe should have paced
myself but you don't think about that in
the moment and and I got and I got stuck
you know and it was Thai heat humidity
and heat stroke got me and there's
nothing you could do at that point other
than tell yourself move on or die
essentially like I knew there was not an
ambulance closed we were in the middle
of the jungle so I think survival
mentality kicked in not what am i doing
next right and what you said they're
really kind of illuminates what cam said
when she was like Cara you got to leave
him because we got to go and get this
done so the fact that you had told them
prior like if it's me like just go I've
got a limb it's a lot because in the
moment I was like wait what they're just
yeah
what so that's why cam was following
orders like I trusted cam with a lot of
a lot of my gameplay this season her and
I were like always on the same page
I knew if somebody had to be a savage it
was gonna be her and you know because I
was like look I was like it's it's for
the money I'm like you know if we can
carry somebody who could carry somebody
but you know on top of carrying the
gurney nobody was gonna be carrying me
in that condition so I had to figure out
how to will myself forward yeah
absolutely and speaking of carrying you
were doing a lot of the heavy lifting at
the beginning of that stage of the
challenge you were taking it on you were
you were really pushing through it's a
tough challenge and I noticed that your
team actually has a lot of height
difference so the way that you guys
carry stuff is very different than kind
of a level playing field with that
gurney so what was your thought process
going into that challenge and really
kind of taking it on those first two
legs you know honestly I had thought
that we were gonna follow the same
strategy as the UK with three guys
carrying every single time somebody
rotating out the the height difference
on everybody was crazy so like there's a
lot of physics that goes into it I'm a
science nerd exercise science major so
like trying to figure that out was very
difficult and you know with Zack out of
the rotation I understand you know we
had to try and figure out how to save
who was gonna go where in hindsight I
think it would have been better to put
the taller people in the back shorter
people in front so even though I was
taller than the ninja it would have been
better to have ninja next to Cara Lee
Roy next to myself and that would have
been a different weight distribution but
ultimately I made the decision to ride
to the finals with that entire group of
people like even the people on the UK
side you know - strong inventory
unfortunately so I kind of felt
compelled to pick up the slack if there
was any slack because a lot was riding
on on me because a lot everybody trusted
me to get there so everybody was looking
at me too
you know if there was a situation like
that and I should have been smarter in
the moment I wasn't I've been blessed
see as far of the game as possible in
these three seasons to be able to learn
what has been things that I can take
with his positives and things that were
mistakes so if I could go back I think I
would have maybe just told Zach to like
stay on there with me because we needed
them or would it kind of tried to figure
out the rotation because it's not like
we had to we couldn't we couldn't rotate
somebody in but the four people that
were on during whichever leg it was we
could have switched around where we were
standing and I think we could've did
that or figured out like a rest and go
period like hey guys lets somebody count
it out let's walk for five minutes rest
for two minutes walk for five minutes
rest for two minutes we only had one
camel back so I mean hindsight is always
20/20 right when you're in the moment
you can look back and think of all the
different ways you can change it but
yeah you were in the moment you know yes
sometimes you think let me be the hero
or like you know in the case of war the
world's won I was like it would look
really cool if I drove headfirst in
hindsight that compacted my neck and you
know thankfully you know didn't snap or
you know or worse but you live and learn
absolutely so you did mention that the
Alliance that you had assembled was your
writer dive this was like a strong group
from the jump we all saw it and we also
you guys just get stronger and stronger
as a unit and as competitors throughout
the season there's been a lot of
discussion about that Alliance and how
many of you did not even see an
elimination round period what do you say
to the people that are questioning the
fact that you guys didn't compete really
you had a easy right to the final
quote-unquote what it what is your
response to that you know we don't get
to pick the format of the game we just
go there and we figure it out I had
nobody really going into it I once I saw
it was a political style game I
immediately went to how Derrick and Cody
played their season a big brother and I
started picking pieces from some of the
greats
who
played Big Brother you know like like
the Rachel Riley's The Dandy slings like
all these people who not only were good
strategically but good socially and it's
not as easy as it looks to have nobody
hit an elimination floor and and
speaking from everybody else I mean
everybody was carrying their weight I
mean when it came to the dailies me and
Jordan were passing back and forth the
number one and number two competitors
every single daily so like you I can
understand if you were just sitting back
but you know cams proven herself in
eliminations ninjas proven herself in
eliminations I've proven myself in
eliminations car has we all have there's
seasons where people just don't see
eliminations I think what happened was
is we figured out the political game so
well that we were able to keep the
cushions on both sides to make sure
nobody saw an elimination I mean that's
that's hard to do
is it the style that I like now I hate
the political style game I prefer we're
the world's one where it's like win
you're safe lose you either get voted in
and you could call out anybody or if
somebody's down there they can call you
out that's that's what I love but I'm
not gonna sit there and if I show up and
it's a different format be like well
that's it yeah I should just not try and
you know there were points where I was
sitting there preparing myself to be
like well if a ninja loses to Laurel I'm
going in next you know if if if bananas
beat Theo I'm a dead man you know what I
mean like little things like I think the
main thing that we did is we capitalized
on every single mistake and the other
side just kept making mistakes and
that's the main difference yeah I think
you know your veteran status in the game
and it's it's it's new word but I think
all of you who had played the game wala
socially and politically before it your
skills jumped out and I think you know
that's the only thing you can say about
it and watching it and made for a very
entertaining season as a fan and I think
a lot of people are just kind of a
little shocked by kind of how everything
shook down yeah
were you shocked like were you shocked
like how well you guys were able to kind
of control the game I was I was shocked
I was sitting there I swear I remember
sitting there and I remember speaking to
one of the producers in an interview and
they're just like oh how are you how do
you know that the things that are
working out are going to work out and I
was like I don't I was like but I was
like everybody's looking at me to be a
leader figure I was like I have to put
on this front of it's gonna work trust
me 100% like if if we do this this this
and this this is gonna happen guaranteed
it's almost like a fake it till you make
it mindset so if there is one check one
thing you could change throughout this
season what would it be because you
played a pretty flawless game I mean the
final is the final and at that point
it's just it's up to your team that
you've assembled so what is one thing do
you have any regrets is there one
specific moment you can pinpoint to be
like maybe I should have done that you
know I can honestly say I don't regret
anything this season because I'm one of
those people where I don't I don't care
if I'm if I'm portrayed as the villain
or if I'm controversial or if or if you
know if there's half the people who love
me half the people who hate me I'm gonna
play the game the way that it's meant to
be played I I'm not going to do things
in order to gain the you know the the
empathy and the sympathy and everything
I've never been one to want to play
victim and honestly like it meant
something to me to ride with a bunch of
people because I kind of get the I get
pinned with the untrustworthy person
like you can't trust Paulie and you know
it honestly comes from big brother but
it comes from my first season of final
reckoning but I mean one of the worlds
one I didn't have anybody and I just
competed and I just rode so there was no
such thing as trustworthy untrustworthy
I went after the people who I wanted to
go after
this season working with all the people
that I worked with you know I wanted
them to trust me not just for this
season but for future seasons you know
if I'm if I'm blessed to ever be on any
future seasons but I wanted to show like
look there's people who are gonna say
I'm not trustworthy and don't like me
but were they working with me no the
people were working with me what did
they say about me you know what I mean
like am i trustworthy to them you gotta
roll with the punches you know you can't
you can't go back I feel like there's
less honor and going back and saying all
right what did this I would did this or
what did this like know I did what I did
I can take the heat whether whether we
win or lose I'm gonna take the heat
because I assembled that team I was the
leader I was the captain essentially so
as the captain when you win it's because
of the team when you lose it's because
you write so I knew going into the final
that's what was riding on this if we won
it's because of the team we lose I'm
taking heat for it because this is the
team that I assembled this is a team
that I've that I rode with and I and you
own it and I appreciate that the fact
that you said that because I do have a
lot of people forget about that people
forget that you know these games are
designed in a certain way production
does have an app there's an aspect of
production that's working behind the
scenes that you guys may not be aware of
and I think there's a lot more that goes
into it then a lot of people know I
plead the fifth I can't speak on that
however I am I'm very aware of my role
when it comes to these shows and you
know if someone comes to me and says hey
you got to be the bad guy I'm a bad guy
if they're like hey you gotta you know
we got to see this we guys do that uh
you know I'll do the best of my ability
you know what I mean
gotcha you got a you got to be a team
player essentially because whether you
win or lose
ultimately you want to make great show
and if the show is great then that means
more people have jobs more people get to
come back
more people's careers get to last longer
get to last you know until they wanted
to end essentially in and that's where
my mind says sides compete first but
when you realize it's when you realize
how it's gonna be
you just gotta own it like there's no
sitting there being like oh but don't
tweet bad things about me
don't don't love me love it's like no I
get it I know why there's people
tweeting brutal things about me I mean I
have never seen in my life almost
breaking my neck and then almost dying
of heatstroke
people cheering for it you know like
being like yeah I loved every second of
seeing you died but ultimately I get it
I know that there's been some chatter
about you and Cara Maria skipping this
next season that's currently filming
what can you say about why you guys
chose to not be there I can't really
dive too much into it because there's a
lot to be behind the scenes stuff
happened all I can say is when it comes
to the challenge it's a competition show
so I think that my fellow competitors if
they're really competitors they need to
understand it's a competition show and
what had happened with me is there's a
group there's a group of people who may
be upset with me rightfully so right but
so try and do a lot outside of the show
in order to keep me from going and
competing for your own personal gain and
own personal reasons I think that's when
this game is gonna start getting really
shaky and really dirty because that's
not that's not what it's about
I take the game off the table when I'm
done and when it comes to carve she she
is and she said that she's wanted a
mental break for a long time and it's
rough when you make it back to back to
back and in her case back to back to
back to back to back
you have very little downtime to recover
your body and recover your mental space
so regardless of whatever reasons can be
spoken about and cannot be spoken about
it's a blessing in disguise I've started
a lot of things outside the show that
I'm very proud of that I'm excited about
mainly so my body was taking a beating
like I put my body on the line heavy and
I'm using this time to reload my body
and reload my brain so that you know if
I'm ever blessed to come back I'm coming
back in the best shape I've ever been in
and the best mental shape I've ever been
in and you know and go from there
amazing what we will look forward to
seeing you at your best next time you
enter the challenge house so thank you
so much Paula - I appreciate it
thank you